it's all like an open book diary for me
to be myself you know I'm just a kid
from the u.s. skating that's like where
I came from
me and my friends we participated in
street wear for like the three or four
life cycles of it I grew up printing my
own t-shirts and giving them the friends
or the local skate things and then that
era was dead supreme is my Louis Vuitton
this to me is a Margiela of its time
there's no stylist to style ourselves
whatever feels comfortable but then who
is going to be designing who of that
that generation with all these t-shirt
brands is actually going to parlay and
play with capital F fashion so that they
respect it out of all that I wanted to
do off light I'm just a creative person
and I'm fortunate enough to be
surrounded by people that are 10 times
more creative than me ten times more
visionary than me you know I'm fortunate
to have Kanye as a friend and a mentor
and I know that the kids beneath me
they're visionaries before their time I
don't revolt against anything the only
thing that I work against is the fact
that no one told me I could do this as a
job some of the rest of my career is
like showing kids like yeah you can do
it too like there is no wall you know
it's a generation of us and I think the
one thing that brings us together is
that we just want to push ultra forward
have a say in what goes on